what happens if you're a man with
regular levels of testosterone and you
give yourself a little boost from like
an actual testicular Health aspect
you're essentially shutting down the
signal to them in order to minorly
elevate your levels just for some
hopeful Improvement I know like there's
some women who get pregnant and then
they're just kind of like calm and happy
and like just like pregnant yeah and I
just went like batshit crazy if you're
not literally dying good luck getting
anything in Canada like you better show
up to the ER like physically having a
heart attack yeah yeah or else you're
not getting anything so okay I can get
behind that
[Music]
Eric nice to meet you thanks for coming
on my podcast you as well thanks for
having me
uh how did you like what's your
background for people who aren't aware
or familiar with you um can you give a
brief background about who you are and
what it is you do
um yeah so uh my name is Derek I started
a YouTube channel in 2016 as well as a
accompanying website which I'm probably
most well known for
um the channel name is more plates more
dates it's kind of centered around men's
self-improvement for the most part but
um it's kind of just like a catchy name
I came up with at the time that I
thought was memorable kind of funny and
um since then it's kind of branched out
into multiple different areas and my
interests have evolved since then to be
more focused around biology
Endocrinology pharmacology
performance optimization longevity just
a bunch of different areas like that and
I guess secondarily I'm most known for
my preventative medicine platform as
well as supplement company but mainly
it's the channel which
you know I produce a bunch of content
around
um I don't know just how the human body
works nutrition optimization stuff like
that and um yeah it's kind of a high
level overview hopefully that is a
sufficient summation of what I do I
guess yeah no that works uh okay so what
do you think the main focus for men
should be for overall health health or
say the top three focuses for men
ah
um high quality sleep for sure I think a
lot of people are burning the candle at
both ends and are not really dialing in
their either their circadian rhythm is
out of whack they are you know not
getting into bed at an adequate time and
then also not following a regular
schedule and then even when they're
doing that they're sleep even if it's
eight hours it's oftentimes segmented or
not like high quality enough to actually
break the rewards out of it that they
could otherwise be getting and that's
massively impactful on many different
hormone systems most notable I think
that most are aware of is how
detrimental it is the testosterone
levels in men so I would say that's
probably like the biggest low-hanging
fruit because that's the only like
restorative time of the day where your
body can actually deal with you know
cancer cell proliferation recovery from
your workouts
um also mental health massively impacted
by quality of sleep for sure
um so I would say that's like the
biggest thing and then secondarily to
that as your you are well aware in diet
quality hugely impactful for sure I
would say a lot of people are very
focused on macronutrients like protein
carbs fats they Count Their calories
that's kind of like the extent a lot of
people go to even those who are trying
to be mindful of their health but a lot
of times people Overlook micronutrient
density of foods as well as mineral
intake and things that go I don't know
like there's a lot of people that will
use like low calorie Alternatives or
sugar-free Alternatives but then they're
totally void of any sort of nutritional
value whatsoever yeah other than like oh
it's high protein and no sugar so
therefore good
not always the case because a lot of
these vitamins and minerals are like
cofactors for different things in your
body that are necessary for optimizing
performance uh Vitality Etc
um so there's that and then
I guess exercise third like what the
original question was three like main
thing yeah yeah that's probably the best
I could pull out of my ass off the top
of my head huh sleep okay my sleep has
been garbage for about two weeks and I
feel like I don't feel good because of
it I just I don't know I got into this
like just into the going to sleep at two
o'clock in the morning just just it like
normally my sleep schedule is on point
it's like 10 o'clock early in the
morning and then for a couple weeks I
had so you know I'm on this carnivore
diet and I had these amazing sausages
made so I had like meat shipped
somewhere and I had these sausages made
and I guess they went through a meat
grinder that had other things in it and
it just screwed up my sleep and I've
been
it's amazing how much you need to
optimize sleep what could people do or
what if they have interrupted sleep
um like I guess as far one of the main
things is people waking up to go to the
washroom in the middle of the night so
that's one of the biggest Interrupters
for sure that could be mitigated through
electrolyte balance so having a
sufficient balance of sodium potassium
calcium magnesium a lot of people are
not really focusing on Mineral intake
and their electrolytes
um as well as just being very mindful of
how much water you're drinking before
you go to bed like I'd say that's
probably the number one like actual
physical impediment to staying asleep as
people waking up and having to go take a
piss for sure
um but other than that like actual Sleep
Quality caffeine timing definitely huge
a lot of people don't consider the
half-life of caffeine is five plus hours
and depending on how old you are you are
your metabolism of the caffeine gets
worse and worse over time So eventually
it takes longer to work its way out of
your system in that you know afternoon
coffee that you had on top of your
morning coffee could be screwing you up
you know later into the night when you
think you know you just assume the
caffeine is not in your system because
you don't feel you know upbeat and
energetic anymore but in reality the
residual effects are still preventing
you from getting that really deep sleep
um yeah and there's a bunch of other
things too but I mean those are probably
the two main ones off the top of my head
to be honest so are you a fan of uh
high salt
what about high salt well I mean just a
lot of salt consuming a lot of salt you
talked about electrolytes so are you a
fan of like extra electrolytes for
optimization
um it depends on the individual like I
wouldn't just broad spectrum sweepingly
say everyone should be adding salt to
their diet necessarily because a lot of
people can have you know go into
elevation of blood pressure when they
have added salt salt to their diet when
they don't necessarily utilize it but
yeah that could be impactful for sure
for actually uh avoiding excessive
urination you know and I think caffeine
also does have a mild diuretic effect so
if you are loading up on caffeine you
can imagine that that's gonna make you
urinate more as well so things to be
mindful of for sure
so what's your background in like do you
have educational wise or education wise
do you have um education and nutrition
or or anything like that or that's the
interesting thing is for me a lot of
people think like I remember Joe Rogan
for a while thought I was a chemist
because I had I don't know this like
rumor started that I was like this
Meathead chemist
um and a lot of people wonder exactly
what I do but I had a undergrad in
marketing and totally useless by the way
like I would not necessarily recommend
it for anybody yeah but
um yeah my education formally is just on
the business administration side of
things but
um nothing really relevant to what I'm
passionate about or pursue nowadays and
mainly my education is self-taught as
well as through collaboration with other
individuals that I respect and um you
know find Mutual benefit in you know
educating each other keeping up to date
on the newest literature of
Endocrinology whatever it is and through
of my preventative medicine platform as
well we have a lot of doctors who I kind
of indirectly get to absorb like a
sponge a lot of their findings through
their work with patients directly
because they talk about stuff in
clinical chats all the time there's
meetings all the time I can kind of
indirectly absorb information through
them as they work with patients in real
time and then I'm also just like a huge
nerd and I just read studies all the
time
yeah okay so tell me more about this
platform
okay it's called Uh Merrick health and
essentially it is targeted for broad
spectrum optimization so it's not like a
typical I'm sure you've heard of trt
clinics trt is becoming like a very very
popular almost trendy fad nowadays where
a lot of people are haphazardly jumping
on testosterone replacement that may
otherwise not even need it but our
platform tries to I kind of
differentiate it in a way that it's
focused on optimizing all things from a
natural angle to and then also assessing
other kind of diagnostic metrics that
could evaluate you know things from your
lipid Health you know for cardiovascular
disease risk you know things like cancer
markers and essentially when you come
into our Clinic you find you'll get
teamed up with somebody a provider who
will
kind of evaluate your Diagnostics and
then make targeted recommendations for
optimization from a health perspective
Vitality optimization perhaps hormones
and it's kind of just like uh okay yeah
it's like basically ties in exactly with
what I'm most passionate about and I can
actually like impart that information to
people who follow me that's very cool
yeah so my husband watches quite a bit
of Mind pump okay for about for about
six months he was like my testosterone's
low it's definitely low testosterone and
I need to get on testosterone and I was
like I don't know I'm so skeptical I
don't know very much about hormones I
know quite a bit about nutrition and
from having the autoimmune disorder I
know quite a bit about
I know some anyway you can Define quite
a bit but I know some things but I don't
really know anything about hormones and
I was like I don't know injecting
testosterone seems like if you don't
need it first of all seems like a bad
idea and I know that there are a lot of
people
on it and there are a lot of people who
say there are benefits to adding in
testosterone what happens if you're a
person with like a man with regular
levels of testosterone and you give
yourself a little boost
um well it depends if you give yourself
a little boost as in you push yourself a
bit higher than what you are naturally
essentially yeah you know you're
essentially shutting down your entire
um not your entire reproductive system
but from like an actual testicular
Health aspect you're essentially
shutting down the signal to them in
order to minorly elevate your levels
just for some
hopeful Improvement in cognitive
sharpness you know muscle building
potential Etc like oftentimes I think
people are misdiagnosed through poor
lifestyle and diet habits and they will
haphazardly jump on T because they have
a they go into a you know a Lab Corp or
whatever it is they get a testosterone
test done they transiently through one
snapshot in time one moment they had a
you know 250 total testosterone level
and then they interpret that as all it
must be low T perpetually and it's
negatively impacted my life I need to
get on trt but there's all the
low-hanging fruit even that we addressed
at the beginning those were just a
couple of things those things are so
impactful and testosterone production
that if you overlook those and jump
right to the drug route you could be
overlooking things that could get you
back to a healthy State otherwise
without the necessity to rely on these
hormones so I think a lot of people some
people do need it for sure and there's
like absolute utility in and it's very
very effective when it's needed and
warranted but a lot of people I think
haphazardly get on it and may not
otherwise need it and then they end up
reliant on it for their entire lives
okay okay so what what ended up
happening with my husband is he was
having tree allergies so he was tired
then that was the end of the story and
now he's not having them so it was like
that would have been a brutal a brutal
reason to get on for sure yeah
uh okay so you said Reliant so is there
actually no way to get off of it once
you're on it so if you're a healthy
functioning male with good testosterone
levels prior
if you got off within like a reasonable
time frame like
you know there's not really a reasonable
time frame for replacement because
you're supposed to be replacing what you
otherwise don't have so it's like you're
essentially you know using something
you're you're artificially shutting down
your system that otherwise didn't need
to be and you could get back to your
natural function
dependent on the duration of exposure so
if you've been doing trt for like 15
years or something and you technically
didn't need it when you started it are
you going to be able to recover to
Natural function if you then decide oh I
want to try and come off
it kind of depends because again it's
almost like there is a use it or lose it
kind of thought process that goes into
different organs in your body so if you
shut down the signal to your testicles
for a decade and a half and you have
like shriveled atrophy testicles and
then you try to recover to Baseline it's
not as simple as just pulling out the
testosterone and then everything just
works correctly perfectly like you're
gonna deal with a very very arduous
recovery phase whereby you might end up
hating your quality of life so much on
that recovery phase that you just end up
staying on this on the testosterone now
for some people though if they were
totally healthy like for example your
husband if he was to get on test didn't
need it and then was like you know what
it's not for me came off after like
three months or something he might have
like a transient phase where he kind of
feels shitty while it's kind of like
leaving a system and then his normal
pituitary is kicking back in but
enough you'd probably recover to
Baseline within relatively short order
once the drug had worked its way to the
system yeah okay so that's not like
massive risk if you're testing it out
yeah no but I would definitely caution
against what I'm testing testing yeah
okay
um how did you how did you go from a
YouTube channel like a popular YouTube
channel to running that kind of massive
business did you did you have a change
like did you have a plan or is this
something that just kind of happened and
you went with it
um you know I much like a lot of
businesses that people find themselves
in I I very rarely believe that people
especially in the social media space
really predicted where they'd be five
years ahead of schedule when they first
start so for me it was uh I didn't I
didn't even know if I should be making
videos when I started online like I
literally just started writing articles
somebody told me suggested I should also
do videos with it started making them
um and as my content evolved and whatnot
you start to look into different ways to
monetize especially things that you're
passionate about because after a while
when you start making money you realize
your you know the money you park can
only take you so far the passion is
what's going to actually like drive you
for years so for me this was like the
perfect overlap of monetization and what
I actually am highly interested in and
it sort of just evolved naturally like
uh I found myself seeing some of these
platforms popping up across the USA and
I was just seeing the haphazard cookie
cutter protocols that you know providers
were putting people on just to basic
quickly make a markup on medication
essentially a lot of these companies
exist simply to be like Nat like almost
similar to like the pill mill stuff you
heard about back in the day but like on
the testosterone front a lot of these
companies would basically just you know
evaluate your blood work but not even
really care what it says and be like
here's legal steroids go you know here
you go have fun and that is not I
thought there was a major hole in the
industry for like an actual preventative
medicine approach that is looking for
optimization from optimization from a
dietary perspective sleep hygiene
optimization
um you know hormone optimization if
warranted and just like a broad spectrum
overview approach so that's kind of
where I came into it yeah it's cool
um coming from Canada there aren't as
many terrible
oh it's no I are you in Canada yeah I'm
on the west coast
oh yeah ha I left Canada I'm in Miami
now oh lucky yeah sorry I don't mean to
like laugh at you I didn't know you were
from Canada so is your company based in
Canada no okay
yeah yeah Canada is a rough one to try
and break into because there's a lot of
uh like I I don't know who watching has
had experiences trying to even get a
basic blood test when you're not like 70
years old but if you're not literally
dying good luck getting [ __ ] anything
in Canada like you better show up to the
ER like physically having a heart attack
yeah yeah or else you're not getting
anything so okay I can get behind that
no it's it's shocking it's shocking yeah
it's free but then you get what you pay
for yeah that's one of the things I'm
very very
um optimistic about expansion into
Canada because that's something I've and
partly what motivated this whole thing
to begin with is I've been so frustrated
with the medical system in Canada for a
number of years that I was like why is
it that I literally have to drive over
the Border just to get a blood test
[ __ ] absurd so for me you know being
able to give that access to my parents
to my friends to myself you know that's
the kind of stuff that I want people to
be able to get a proactive approach to
longevity optimization Etc rather than
have to physically like show up having a
heart attack to get some help so
oh okay I like that yeah it's crazy
moving to the U.S uh I've had it's just
there's so many options it's amazing
like I found this company online that
I'm giving a shot because I've got I'm
allergic to everything which is why I'm
on this diet because I like I've got
food allergies I've have everything and
I found this company that does
sublingual immunotherapy so they'll give
you like tiny little doses of like Oak
and Ragweed cockroach dust like
everything and so I'm going to try that
out for the next couple of years to see
if I can reduce
the food allergies and the food
sensitivities so I think there might be
a cross-reactivity issue with the severe
environmental allergens causing the food
sensitivities I'm hoping so if you have
these sublingual like micro doses of of
random stuff like what is that doing
evaluating if you have a allergic
response and then like well what what
you do is you do an allergy test so they
do a prick test right and then and then
decide you know show what you're
allergic to and then they mix that up in
this drop and then you take the drop and
it's supposed to desensitize your system
oh wow yeah it's really interesting
they're doing it for for people with
peanut allergies they've been doing this
for a little bit because you have a kid
with peanut allergies they can just die
right if they're if they don't have the
EpiPen so you can give them tiny tiny
bits of tiny bits of peanuts
sublingually and so they have this tiny
little immune response but you can train
their immune system over like a two or
three year period it takes a while I
think they see results after six months
and so reduce sensitivity that's crazy
that's like uh have you ever heard of
those guys who
intentionally expose themselves to like
snake venom or like some random it's
that okay huh wild I didn't know that
was like an actual therapy crazy yeah
yeah it is uh it's called immunotherapy
you can get it in shots too but there
are these companies popping up I think
there are three of them now in the U.S
where you can go online and order
immunotherapy drops so if you have
triologies you can get this mixture that
slowly desensitizes your immune system
and the results are like it's
theoretically it works it looks like it
works so
um fingers crossed I can one day eat
other things than meat we'll see seems
unlikely yeah maybe it would be nice
yeah this episode of the podcast was
sponsored by paleo Valley beef sticks
it's a health episode kinda so I thought
why not throw these guys in there paleo
Valley's beef sticks are made from 100
grass-fed and grass-finished beef
they're fantastic for snacking if you're
trying to lose weight I give them to
Scarlet for a snack in kindergarten but
they're good for you too if you want
better food and something to eat that
doesn't make you feel like you can't
stop eating it and therefore makes you
gain weight meat doesn't do that paleo
Valley puts their beef sticks through a
natural fermentation process which is
cool which helps nourish and keep your
gut biome healthy paleo valleys beef
sticks come in five different flavor
flavors
paleo Valley's beef sticks come in five
different flavors and all the spices
they use in their beef sticks are 100
organic other beef sticks often use
fillers like mechanically separated
chicken parts
which is just a hilarious thing to add
but you probably shouldn't eat it that
are crushed down chicken parts that are
crushed down into a paste brominated
vegetable oil BVO and MSG which can
cause a myriad of issues paleo Valley's
beef sticks on the other hand are clean
both for you and for the environment
great for kids too all of their cattle
are raised on small American-owned farms
in the U.S that use rotational grazing
practices to help restore the nutrient
content and foliage to grazed pastures
head over to paleoballey.com to check
out their beef sticks today that's
p-a-l-e-o-v-a-l-l-e-y if you're not
entirely sure how to spell paleo Valley
you should just know how to spell it
though paleovalley.com for 100 grass-fed
beef sticks okay so this this uh company
you have that that uh employs doctors
which is very cool
um what's your plan with that do you
have a growth plan or are you kind of
staying where you are
um yeah so right now it's more so just
brand exposure and bringing more people
to spread the message showing up to
different there's a lot of different
kind of like
conferences when it comes to like
there's kind of the
optimization niche of the scientific
Community like a lot of the the Ben
greenfields and like uh of the world and
there's also like the clinical side with
like the Peter ratias and the hubermans
and whatnot and yeah I don't know just
like branching as far out as I can and
trying to spread uh knowledge and also
you know at the same time you know bring
people into what I consider to be high
quality uh medical oversight so you know
for me it's more so just continuing to
make content surrounding the I don't
know issues that we Face from like a
hormone balance perspective anything
Health optimization related and then
bring in like-minded individuals you
want to also import the same message
further educate themselves as well as
others in the process and
um yeah you know I would like to get it
International but it's obviously a very
very large undertaking to when it comes
to licensing and all the different you
know random I don't know like legal
loopholes when it comes to medical stuff
so in the near future hopefully Canada
is on the to-do list and then it's crazy
that you can like as a Canadian that it
was easier it's so much easier in
America to do business it's crazy like I
can't get over it but that's nuts that
you'd I suppose most of your audience is
probably American versus yeah is it yeah
yeah the corporate structure stuff as a
Canadian sucks when you're in the states
like trying to establish like the
companies that hold the companies that
do this but overall like everything in
the states is just Superior overall and
like even before I had even before I had
all this stuff like I used to literally
pay for blood work drive over the border
to Blaine Washington and go to a lab
court myself get my blood drawn get an
email to me and then like interpret the
results and that was how I had to get
blood work back in the day because you
would go to a doctor here and just say
can I get my cholesterol checked and
they'd say no and they get mad at you
because it's like you're trying to tell
me what you need go [ __ ] yourself get
out of my office
that's yeah that seems pretty accurate
yeah no you don't need that yeah I can
imagine what you dealt with growing up
with uh trying to figure out all your
stuff and probably the amount of doctors
that shunned you or told you you're
crazy or or you think you need this test
like you're you know I'll I know what's
correct I'm the doctor you know I still
have oh my gosh I still have anger
issues from that I was like lividly
especially when I ended up putting the
autoimmune disorder into remission with
diet then that just like it blew me away
right especially after the medical
system experience in Canada I was livid
like livid with anger for probably two
and a half years because at that point
um I'd had my ankle replaced in Canada
they'd installed the replacement
slightly crooked so I'd solved the
autoimmunity and I didn't have that
anymore and I was in chronic pain from a
ankle replacement I probably could have
avoided yeah and I I was
anyway I'm not really angry anymore but
I'm not very trusting of doctors I'm
sure the Canadian medical system didn't
help with that at least the Silver
Lining to it though is the information
you have now that you can then impart on
tens of thousands of people like even my
one of my business partners his wife was
on antibiotics during her pregnancy and
then she ended up like wiping out her
gut microbiome essentially and it kind
of like presumably impacted their kid in
a very significant way so they have a
toddler right now
um or an infant I guess I don't know
when you become a Toler what the
difference is age-wise but he's like one
and his his gut is just a disaster like
anything he eats and his entire like
face goes red everywhere becomes red and
he tries to like scratch his face off
because he's so uncomfortable and they
have to put like mittens on him to make
sure he doesn't scratch his face off and
what yeah so like some of the
information that
um you you know Paul saladino some of
these uh you know the autoimmune
experienced individuals who have kind of
got their stuff into remission via this
kind of like wild out there you know
Elimination Diet you know that
information was not available you know
10 plus years ago so you had a lot of
like babies being put on corticosteroids
long term which is going to like
significantly hinder their growth you
know and impact them in so many bad ways
so
um like even now that uh they're trying
to see if they can do some sort of
elimination style diet while they
rebuild this gut microbiome and then
kind of reintroduce more diversity as it
gets older kind of thing
yeah they should do it um I was really
paranoid so my daughter's five and I was
really paranoid about her like
microbiome just everything allergies
like everything to do with her because I
was sick from such a young age and then
I was on antibiotics so often I was like
my microbiome is probably messed up
which means she's gonna be messed up and
like what can I do about that and so I
didn't start ex like I did um meat only
when we were first introducing foods
um and then introduced like one food at
a time and waited and that worked really
well and she does have like she has
environmental allergies and she's got a
host of sensitivities but we were able
to like avoid them because we just did
one food at a time now do you know if
it's like obviously I'm sure you
researched this heavily but how much of
it is genetic versus epigenetic like I
know and maybe I don't know if this is
even a question you can answer but I
know for example if some somebody is
obese
like self-inflictedly obese when they
are pregnant and have a kid you know
they could pass on some of that to their
child and put them in a worse kind of
Baseline position and then they have to
deal with those issues too
does that have any sort of crossover
from like I think you mentioned both of
your parents had
autoimmune issues to some extent yeah my
mom my mom actually recently got
diagnosed with lupus which she's not on
medication for it she's she's on the
same diet as me but that explains like
arthritis and some organ issues and like
some eye issues so lupus and my dad had
um
psoriasis and alopecia at one point gum
disease like just not like not great for
both I have a brother he's totally fine
I have no idea how that happened
estrogen is very impactful on autoimmune
issues so typically you'll find that for
example Hashimoto's thyroiditis is an
autoimmune issue that attacks the
thyroid and in general it's very very
majorly affecting women relative to men
and it's because of estrogen's impact on
the on the immune system seemingly so
women are I wonder
that's that's really interesting okay I
have a question I don't know if you know
the answer to this though
um a lot of the people I've spoken with
who've had autoimmunity and are on like
the lion diet or or the carnivore diet
um have gotten significantly
worse or got worse whatever their
problem was after having children and
for me I actually put myself into
remission on a very restrictive paleo
diet so it was super clean I was eating
like 25 foods which I thought was
restrictive but I didn't have any
symptoms and then I had scarlet and
that's when I went over to the meat only
diet because my autoimmune flared up do
you know anything about pregnancy
exacerbating autoimmunity
um I would imagine the massive
fluctuation in hormones from a
progesterone estrogen aspect throughout
that process would have very significant
implications on that how they would go
to like as far as the metrics of
hormones before pregnancy during and
then after and reaching Baseline I
couldn't tell you off the top of my head
exactly what in general they do but I
would imagine and this is kind of where
the utility of having Baseline blood
work comes in and why I recommend
anybody get like an extensive panel
regardless if they're going to go on trt
or not like anything because if
something goes awry being able to look
back and see what was my Baseline when I
was healthy and what is weird and
aberrant now can be very very helpful
for actually like owning in and figuring
out what might be screwing you up so
from like a hormone metabolism aspect
and just balance of everything like I
would imagine there could be something
there for sure like I know postpartum
depression is
um I believe lack of progesterogenic
activity from the manip the changes in
progesterone activity in the body so
having that crash or be non-existent or
you know decrease whatever it may be
could be something that leads to like
anxiety depression mood swings just like
a lot of major issues and
um they've actually developed drugs
around trying to like replicate the same
things that you get from like adequate
amounts of natural hormone production
from progesterone for example so
um yeah there's definitely I would
imagine something very impacted by the
hormone balance side of things after for
sure and that's where you know a good uh
elaborate blood test I think would be
highly warranted compared to a baseline
beforehand
yeah that's a very good idea
um regarding progesterone from what you
know about the topic is that
not enough progesterone to begin with or
those like Downstream problems like it's
not getting converted properly or
something
um I believe it's not enough in general
um typically people who have conversion
issues are people who are using drugs
that impact
enzymatic Pathways like for example guys
who use finasteride for preventing hair
loss there's an enzyme called five Alpha
reductase and if you inhibit that enzyme
despite the fact that you're preventing
the hormone DHT from wreaking havoc on
your head you're also preventing the
conversion of different progesterogenic
and metabolites like aloe pregnant alone
is a very very
owned in on one that has like angiolytic
activity and is very very significantly
implicated in like depression outcomes
and whatnot and if you don't have either
a sufficient amount of the substrate to
produce those metabolites so
progesterone being the main thing off
the top of my head that I could think of
that's impactful on that or if you're
using a drug as a male to inhibit that
enzyme then Downstream yeah it could be
problematic but from the female side of
the side of things I would imagine
progesterone lack of thereof is probably
the main needle mover in that side
hmm interesting I had a
pretty miserable pregnancy experience
and I I know like there's some women who
get pregnant and then they're just
they're like they still have pregnancy
hormones but they're kind of like calm
and happy and like just
like pregnant and I just went like
batshit crazy and I could feel like I
could feel hormones and I was like that
doesn't feel like me and it was just it
was bad and it felt like something was
wrong and I had this and I know some
people have miserable pregnancies but it
felt like I went crazy in a way that
wasn't something was like off
um and I was wondering if I spent I
spent the years like age 12 to 23 on
antidepressants
um which can
really increase your progesterone levels
and I was wondering if being on that for
like a decade during my developmental
years screwed up my brain enough that
just some of the pregnancy hormones just
don't make me feel good I can hardly
take any medication now without it
making me feel like terrible in a side
effect way that normal people shouldn't
really have like antihistamines anything
kind of make me crazy
um
side of things
um like as far as female Endocrinology
it's definitely not my like wheelhouse
and again I'm not like a you know a
clinical Specialist or anything I'm just
a guy on YouTube ultimately at the end
of the day so don't take this as medical
advice anybody watching this is why you
would get a high quality medical
provider but from what I have seen I
think uh I think SSRI is like even from
a quick Google search they seem to
impact aloe pregnant alone solely and do
not substantially affect the brain
concentrations of progesterone or
dihydroprogesterone so you know it's uh
it's tough to say too because some
people the way they partition certain
hormones like down certain Pathways to
different metabolites it's different
proportionally and different tissues
have different like you know receptor
expression from that amount of hormone
like even from the testosterone side of
things some people are going to get more
of an effect even though they have less
testosterone on a blood test than
another guy AI because of the way the
receptors interact with the hormone so
it's tough to say you can't really
predict broad spectrum just because you
have a heightened level on a blood test
or a heightened level
based on what it's supposed to do that
that's going to yield the exact effect
you're looking for especially when it
might have
like backhanded consequences on Upstream
things that are going on so you know
like extra you know selective serotonin
reuptake inhibition I can't say for
certain
what it did that you know might have
impacted somebody who knows either yeah
like nobody nobody knows um we went I
talked to some Eastern European doctors
and they said they have brain scans that
say that they change
that you could see it on brain scams
like Decades of SSRI use and I was like
wow that's definitely not something that
we have here at least they don't say
that yeah I think there was some like uh
study that came out recently that said
ssris are like I don't know they they
used to be thought to be
lack of Serotonin was thought to be the
cause of depression and then recently
they were like no that's actually not
the case yeah not at all yeah yeah
they're like there's no evidence that
serotonin plays yeah that type of role
or a lack of Serotonin plays a role in
depression it's like oh yeah all these
people on serotonin increasing drugs but
sometimes it's hard to tell too when
it's like because again when you Circle
back to the low-hanging fruit discussion
it's like how many people on this Earth
are getting six hours of sleep
perpetually have to get up under slept
drive to a job they hate and there's so
many like different factors from a
lifestyle perspective that are so
deleterious to all of the hormone
systems and then they'll blame you know
they'll rely on a drug or this or that
and then they're wondering why the
they're feeling a certain way it's got
to be because of the drug or not because
of the drug when in reality it's like
the Baseline infrastructure that holds
up like the tower so to speak is just
not even set properly to begin with so
it's kind of hard to say for certain
like oh owning in on one specific thing
oh it was definitely yes when we have no
idea about all the like weren't you on
Adderall at the time too when you were
trying yeah
so like I imagine that [ __ ] your sleep
up brutally at the same time so we have
no idea for sure but I would imagine
that has like it's all it's like a
vicious circle effect like sometimes
you'll take a drug to correct an issue
that was caused by some lack of
foundational principles from a lifestyle
perspective and then that using that
might fix something acutely but on the
backhand [ __ ] up the Baseline stuff and
then it's like yeah
I I had things perfected like I did I
mean the Adderall really helped but I I
was on man I was on like seven
medications like immunosuppressants that
I injected and like antibiotics because
they only prescribe extended release
Adderall as far as I know too yeah which
is so it's like if you look at that life
of extended release Adderall and trying
to get a high quality sleep when you're
on like a very very long extended window
literal amphetamine just to function and
then you know you might be having
caffeine on top of that because people
you know how many coffees they have a
day or whatever like trying to get high
quality sleep with that in your system
it's like essentially impossible I would
say yeah so yeah it was crazy I used to
take do you know gravel yep do you know
yeah so I took gravel to sleep at night
for people listening it's like Benadryl
yeah so take Adderall in the morning and
then I take a couple of like gravel at
night and then just repeat but I did
figure out like the perfect combination
of medications to keep me functioning
enough that I figured out how to get off
of everything and fix it with diet so
like I can't say it was all detrimental
because it did put me in a position
where I could at least like function
enough that I thought okay how do I get
out of this like as soon as possible
no but yeah again I think it circles
back to the it's almost it was shitty
they had to go through it but it makes
you more I don't know in a better
position to import that wisdom on people
who might be on the laundry list of the
entire catalog of drugs right now and
maybe you don't need it or whatever I
wouldn't trade it like during the
experiences I think I probably I
remember like you know even praying like
how do I make this stop but now that
it's over it's like if I hadn't gone
through that yeah I wouldn't be able to
tell people about it and lots of people
have reached out and it's helped them
and I'm fine now plus I don't think I
would be as like I'm a fairly
disagreeable disagreeable person and I
don't know what I would be like if I
hadn't had chronic health issues but I
think it probably made me a more
compassionate person especially towards
sick people like I'm not very patient I
don't think and I have a lot of
compassion for people who are sick and I
don't know if
I don't know if I would have that
otherwise so I'm definitely grateful for
that yeah I think there's a lot of
people who are quick to judge somebody
who's overweight or somebody who has an
issue but they have no idea what might
be underlying and leading to that
problem to begin with like maybe they're
dealing with some like very significant
obscure as hell issue that then leads to
all of these like byproduct you know
manifestations of like a not as great
cosmetic appearance or whatever it is
and to be judgmental on that is like if
every comment and unfortunate so it's
good that you went through that for sure
overall I think
how do you feel then about
um the fat acceptance movement
um I think it's not good because being
obese is unhealthy so I think that
shaming somebody who's fat is not good
but I think it is not something that
should be celebrated which is the main
issue that I see in social media is a
lot of these companies it's kind of like
hard to even you can't really blame them
because at the same time so many people
are obese that obviously if you're going
to make clothing for example
you're going to make them for obese
people too so they can fit it because
that's a giant demographic of your you
know customer base so are you gonna put
you know not feature them in
advertisements like at some point you're
gonna have to Market to those people
because they exist and they have to buy
clothes just like every other person
yeah but then if you put out an ad with
an obese person who's like in Fitness
apparel you get [ __ ] on as a company for
trying to like promote fat acceptance
and it's like it's a weird like
double-edged sword because I think on
one hand the companies are very aware of
this too and that it gets like media
hype and attention and clicks but on the
other hand it's like these people need
to wear clothes so it's like
um I think in general the the kind of um
the celebration of obesity which is
something that happens in social media
and Tick Tock culture and stuff is
uh toxic because it definitely does
reinforce bad behavior that ultimately I
think it's not even a debate that it's
not healthy to be holding excessive
amounts of body fat
um but at the same time it's kind of
like you know that double-edged sword
like I said because some people do have
issues that lead to these you know
problems that may be uh less
controllable than the next guy who just
has like a lack of willpower or because
some people just are lazy and [ __ ]
suck at following a diet like that's
just how they are and then there are
some people who legitimately have
epigenetics passed on from their fat as
hell parents that led to like poor
satiety
um appetite signaling feedback systems
or whatnot and they're perpetually
dealing with heightened levels of hunger
compared to the next guy who just feels
satisfied off of a thousand calories
less per day and then is that person
just like you know a worse off a person
who just has low willpower or is it that
their literal brain chemistry is wired
differently than this person you know
it's definitely a very interesting
discussion but I think uh more
compassion needs to be taken to it from
both sides of the spectrum
I like that I like that I I agree too I
think that encouraging it and saying
that it doesn't cause health problems is
an issue
um but there just needs to be more
education about how to get out of that
like I would have but it's also tricky
dealing with people who are in a kind of
a Health crisis I can remember
I never had someone come up to me and go
oh you know maybe you should try an
Elimination Diet because maybe your
body's inflamed maybe you're having
allergic reactions like I never had that
conversation yeah
um but whenever anybody did mention
any type of kind of alternative approach
to health I can remember being angry at
them like in an inappropriate way it was
like how dare you tell me that my
problems are solved that easily and I
had like severe problems
um but it's hard to speak to sick people
who've been trying things for a very
long time and then saying oh well maybe
you just didn't try this
properly yeah yeah like telling a person
who's fat it's just like you idiot just
eat less like sometimes it's not yeah
like even though that is ultimately will
make you lose weight like there are
other complications that can lead to you
know maybe if you dealt with the same
hormone signaling as that person maybe
you'd be fat too like you don't you
don't know for sure you know so yeah
because some people literally will have
like uh for example if they had an
autoimmune issue that was attacking
their thyroid and then they have a lack
of thyroid hormone output that regulates
their metabolism and then no matter what
they eat you know their actual
metabolism is at a lowered set point
than the next person they can't
necessarily control that inherently just
through lifestyle changes or like how
much exercise they're doing necessarily
and they might just have less T3 than
the next guy or craft T3 because their
thyroid has been destroyed by this
autoimmune issue for years you know
telling that person just like eat less
and exercise it's not as simple as that
or a guy with crashed testosterone being
like just get in the gym and lift some
weights for bro like it's a bit
different when you literally have no
motivation no Drive craft testosterone
Your libido's non-existent Sleep Quality
is terrible you know it's definitely a
nuanced uh discussion
interesting okay I definitely had that
maybe I should go through some of your
blood tests I kind of like uh all my
symptoms went away with the diet and
then I was kind of like ah goodbye
medical system I've seen you enough
um
um although now I'm trying this
sublingual immunotherapy for
environmental allergies so we'll see
what that does but I definitely have the
like can't stop eating I don't have that
on the carnivore diet but I had that
and I have like excellent self-control
like I'm on this diet now I'm like hyper
conscientious
um I I think I have good self-control
but I really had difficult time stopping
eating whenever I was eating anything
and even now if I introduce something
that has a different ingredient then I'm
just like switch into
I'll just eat the entire thing so I
don't like I was never one of those
people that could like have a little bit
of like a cake or a cookie or something
it was always like
now that's all I want
and I'm starving yeah yeah some of those
Foods I think are just like they're not
even food at the end of the day so
trying to judge your I don't know
ability to regulate portion control when
you're eating something that is like
hyper palatable and isn't even enough
isn't even an actual food item is not I
don't think it's representative
necessarily of you know willpower or
self-control but so you don't think
anyone like is there is there one person
that can eat one cookie and be like oh
yeah I definitely know people who do do
that and I look at them I'm like that's
something wrong with them yeah yeah yeah
some people are fine my brother is like
that just have a little bit of a cupcake
like What It's Like Cocaine yeah yeah I
can't even keep it in the house yeah
yeah yeah okay okay well that makes me
feel better uh so these blood tests
you're talking about what what type of
markers should everyone just go get
tested so that at least they have a
Baseline
um yeah so we have uh pre-designed
panels on the site for both men and
women from and depending on budget it
gets more comprehensive the deeper you
go and some of them are like more
elaborate to then be insightful for if
you were going to pursue something like
hormone replacement if you're
post-menopausal or if you're a man with
low T whatever it is there's more
comprehensive metrics that are you know
more expensive and elucidate more stuff
but in general from like a baseline
perspective I think
cardiovascular disease is still one of
the number one Killers so getting a high
quality lipid panel that assesses your
you know a kind of potential for
atherosclerosis I think is definitely
warranted at least to see what your
current diet model and lifestyle is
yielding as far as you know atherogenic
particles and whatnot
um I think getting like a basic complete
blood count is definitely reasonable
um thyroid markers probably a good thing
to check as well
um basic Kidney Health liver function
it's called like a metabolic panel it's
kind of like the standard summation I
don't know it's like a subcategory of
pretty much every panel we have I think
so I've definitely checked that
um I guess in general from a hormone
perspective above and beyond the thyroid
getting your sort of gonadotropins it's
like your LH and FSH your luteinizing
hormone follicle stimulating hormone if
you are a man especially it definitely
worthwhile to see how much signaling you
have to your testes to actually produce
testosterone because some people yeah so
getting not just your total tea and
figuring out how much testosterone I
have but also Upstream to that
why do I have low T or why is my tea
where it is seeing how much of a signal
you have from your brain down to your
testicles is worthwhile because then you
can kind of evaluate is it my testicles
are non-responsive to the signal or is
it that I have a lack of signal and then
why is that the way it is and kind of
getting a more comprehensive Outlook as
to why you are functioning the way you
are and if it's you know a lack of sleep
or micronutrient intake or whatever it
is because some people who are low T
your diagnosis and what you get treated
with Will differ or lack thereof will
differ very very significantly based on
do you have enough signal going to your
testes but they're just not responding
to it because at that point you know
that's where something like a
intervention with therapy becomes more
warranted because it's like you
literally have testicular failure
whereas for another guy who's Low T
because of lifestyle and his sleep sucks
his diet sucks whatever he might have
low T but it's like his LH and FSH are
super low too because he just is
everything from the Baseline Foundation
is terrible so that sort of thing is
insightful to see are you haphazardly
getting on testosterone therapy you
don't need it and if so what could you
do to then optimize like the whole
reproductive access kind of thing so
getting your LH and FSH checked I think
it's definitely worthwhile total
testosterone but above and beyond that
your free testosterone this is like the
hormone that is not like it's called
free because it's not bound to these
like binding proteins in your blood that
kind of like bring it around to Target
tissues and free is kind of the number
that dictates how much is actually
freely available to do stuff and actual
tissues in the body so getting a total
and a free is definitely worthwhile
um and all of these it sounds really
complicated like how would you know
people probably thinking do I need to
write notes or whatever like any good
panel will have all of these things in
it as is
um as well getting a fasting insulin
hugely hugely hugely overlooked a lot of
people are just checking fasting glucose
but fasting insulin is going to be very
worthwhile to see how insulin sensitive
you are and this is one of the biggest
tie-ins to like checking pre-diabetes
risk as well as you know cancer cell
development potentially I think getting
a fast the insulin is definitely very
worthwhile
um vitamin D A lot of people are very
deficient in vitamin D I definitely
think that's worth checking
um C reactive protein that's an
inflammation marker that I think is
worth checking as well there's a bunch
of stuff like I could go on all day but
those are kind of like the low hanging
fruit I would say
um off the top of my head yeah I think
that's a lipoprotein little a is part
could be part of a good lipid panel as
well
um but other than that that sounds like
a lot of stuff and it's very very
complicated to wrap your head around
it's like holy [ __ ] I don't even want to
get this done because it sounds so
complicated but that's where having you
know just a panel that's made for you
everything's done and then somebody
interprets it for you who's qualified is
definitely worth the money in my opinion
that's cool yeah maybe we'll do another
one of those I'm going to be coming up
on five years on this diet five years in
December isn't that crazy this is crazy
so I'll probably do maybe I'll do a
bunch of blood work to prove I'm not
dying see what's going on what inspired
you to do it was it Sean Baker or before
that or how did you arrive at it uh well
I so initially I went down the like I
was in biomedical science and I was
doing all these tests like blood tests
just everything to try and figure out
what was wrong with me I did my family
tree I got everyone to Do genetics tests
to see if there was some weird
Gene thing that was going on
um and I got to the paleo diet just to
rule diet out like because I didn't
think it was playing a role and I wasn't
eating that unhealthy I was eating a lot
of like chicken and broccoli and rice
like so I'd gotten to that point and
then I was like well maybe I'll get rid
of everything I could possibly be
allergic to just to see so like
eggs and shellfish and soy and like nuts
and Grains and I really cut down as much
as I thought was like healthy and that
basically put me into remission in like
a month that was a paleo diet it was
crazy I was eating mostly like sweet
potatoes and carrots and meat but I was
still eating like some fruit like it
wasn't like crazy restrictive
um and then everything was like pretty
good I got off all my medication and I
got a lot more sensitive to Foods when I
stopped taking the ssris like stopping
the ssris just
like destroyed me and I I didn't know
what was happening at the time because I
didn't know that they could cause
physical dependence so I stopped take
like I stopped taking Adderall and I was
like maybe I'll be tired and I stopped
taking some of these medications but I
stopped taking SS Horizon was just like
I should feel better and I didn't I felt
much worse my food sensitivities went up
but I had them kind of under control
with paleo and I got pregnant and then
my autoimmune symptoms came back and I
was on this like restrictive diet that
had worked before and it didn't work
anymore and I was like
desperate because my depression came
back my arthritis came back I was itchy
everywhere and I was like
is it did I get better in the first
place has it always been like this and
then I figured if I'm itchy everywhere
I'm it's probably not in my head
and so I got desperate and I started
cutting out Foods again and I went down
to like meet and green so I was
literally eating like lettuce and Mead
and I was like maybe I can drop the
lettuce but I hadn't heard of the
carnivore diet I was like I just need to
like have a baseline to not react and I
can reintroduce foods and I didn't but I
was breastfeeding at that time and I
didn't want to
screw myself up because of scarlet and
then one of my I like I sent somebody a
picture of my lunch I was just eating
chicken wings I was like I'm doing this
like again and somebody sent me the
video of Sean Baker on Joe Rogan and
they're like yeah this guy only eats
steak and I was like
okay I will literally do that right like
I didn't even know that was an option
and I was getting some pressure from
in-laws about my diet so I and the baby
and so I was like
worried about
being selfish I guess
um and going on this crazy diet but then
when I saw Sean Baker and that he'd been
on it for years and he was just so chill
it's like yeah it's fine just eat steak
I was like okay
so that's what brought me to it and then
I just haven't been able to
reintroduce anything without having like
what appears to be allergic reactions
which
got me to come to the conclusion that
maybe
I'm having cross-reactivity issues like
sometimes if you're super allergic to
trees you can have oral allergy syndrome
to like apples and stoned fruit stone
fruit pitted fruit yeah fruit with
stones anyway
um and I have that and I was like maybe
it's a cross-reactivity problem and
that's why I'm hypersensitive to food
proteins so what do you think of all
these like sub niches that are stemming
out of the carnivore diet where you have
like the organ meat plus red meat and
fruitcamp and then like red meat only
versus I saw a pretty critical comment
of yours on a saladino podcast recently
and okay okay so I I have an issue I
think I have a more like personal issue
with
some of the things saladino says because
I get the people who come to me to the
lion diet which is literally just like
ruminant animal meat they're people
who've tried everything else and when
they start trying the diet they get
confused so they instead of just like
just eat ruminant meat try to make sure
your electrolytes don't go crazy like
and that's and then wait until see how
you're feeling like give it three months
and then start to reintroduce food it's
pretty simple for someone who's really
sick and
confused and desperate to just just do
this and then wait like calm down just
make it through this and wait and then
you get people who are like oh no you
got to do the you got to do the
supplements you got to deliver
supplements liver supplements are you're
gonna be like liver deficient you got to
do the liver supplements and then it's
like well no you should have juice in
the mornings because you need some extra
glucose make sure you have like three
tablespoons of honey before you go to
bed and it's just like I know for me I'm
still whatever's wrong with me I'm still
too sensitive to introduce any fruit so
people being like oh well no people
always ate fruit you can eat oranges
oranges can be terrible arthritis so
then you have people who are trying the
diet for autoimmunity who are like why
isn't it working and it's because
they're still eating a ton of fruit or
something and the point I was hoping the
point of the diet is like eliminate
everything
and then reintroduce otherwise you're
never going to be able to figure out
what's wrong with you especially if you
have an autoimmune disorder and then the
the supplements like
I'm a fan of electrolytes I wish I had
increased my salt and potassium partic
in particular intake in the first eight
months of carnivore because I had like
muscle cramps and I just dealt with them
which was unpleasant
um but I don't eat organs I've been
doing this for five years
I don't like liver the liver is
disgusting and if you like gag when you
eat it but and then they tell you take
it in a pill it's like maybe you don't
need to eat it if it makes you gag I'm
not I'm not a fan okay that is uh
interesting because one of the first
like podcasts I saw about this stuff was
like I so I saw your podcast with Rogan
your dad's with Rogan
salad saladino with Rogan and then there
was expected Crossover with you and
saladino and then kind of this
all of these different like sub niches
started to like expand into different
verticals of like this is the way to do
it no this is the way to do it and it
definitely adds layers of complexity to
it that can be overwhelming I think for
some people where it's like oh I can't I
can't even start if I don't have a
testicle or like you know or oh my gosh
that or I don't if I don't have that
heart with me I don't like that either
it's like gotta carry around a spleen in
my backpack when I travel like as if
being on the diet doesn't make you
freaky enough you need to carry around
organs
um yeah I think like
my goal with the lion diet anyway is to
give people a place to go if they need
to figure out their issues
and then hopefully they can just
reintroduce foods and and hopefully they
don't have to be stuck on the diet like
I don't think
I have a feeling that I'm not going to
be stuck on it forever I think I can
figure out how to reduce sensitivities
but at least it's a starting point and
then you can reintroduce so if you end
up eating meat fruit maybe greens like
whatever else and that's what makes you
feel good
that's fantastic that's like where I was
at before I had a baby so like I don't
have anything and I think that diet's
way healthier than like standard
American diet so I still like what
saladino is doing because he's saying
here's a healthy diet like yeah that's a
healthy diet but for people with
autoimmunity or like severe like
multiple sclerosis like something
crazily bad
um
then it's frustrating to be like this is
what's going to help you because then
they can sometimes give up well it
didn't work so the carnivore diet's out
yeah when you see like liver King
stories for example it's overwhelming to
even think about how would I even
prepare or Source any of this [ __ ]
because it's like you'll have like bone
marrow like in a in like a bowl beside
him there's this other weird concoction
and then you know a bowl of testicles
and this and that it's just like
the process of even finding even like
high quality red meat like ground bison
or whatever in Canada is terrible it's
actually pretty hard to find but then
finding organs on top of that and
whatnot can be definitely uh could
definitely tip somebody over the edge or
it's like oh like [ __ ] it it's too
complicated for me to even figure out
how to find this stuff let alone start
yeah especially somebody who's like
barely making it out of bed like with an
autoimmune disorder they're like okay
now I have to drop all the foods I like
and go into like food withdrawal and
probably feel worse initially and also
figure out how to eat organs yeah
ew one thing I would say just because it
popped in my head too is a lot of people
who are dealing with this kind of stuff
definitely look at what you're taking as
well not just from a food intake aspect
but also like birth control oh my gosh
yeah like how impactful these things are
on all bodily functions including
autoimmunity for sure when you're using
like a synthetic ethanol estradiol with
the synthetic progestin to like manually
castrate yourself it's going to be
impactful on your food sensitivity
probably so a lot of women who are using
an array of different things
probably are going to be looking at like
it's very hyper-specific focused a lot
of these discussions on what are you
eating that's causing an immune flare
and then they'll forget the Baseline
Foundation of all these medications that
are on that are screwing with them too
so it's not just the lifestyle from your
sleep your diet whatever your exercise
it's also what's all the other stuff
you're taking that could be impacting it
too so definitely worth looking at that
because I think a lot of people they'll
literally go years not even thinking
about the medications they're taking and
how those might be impacting everything
else and they look at you know the stuff
that they think it must be like if you
even come to the conclusion that it's
your food you're eating like you're
already pretty deep down the rabbit hole
but then I think oftentimes it gets like
hyper focused on and then they forget
about some of this other stuff too so I
think it's actually so that that's
actually so true um I probably haven't
spoken about that enough when I like for
my blog and everything I say okay like
eventually you have to get off of
everything because and like I told you
earlier I can't take I can't take
anything you know I can't take zinc
without it stopping me from sleeping
like I really can't take
um
anything
uh so but I was so I was on so many
medications and then diet
helped me so much that
it didn't like it didn't occur to me as
much my dad though he got rid of a whole
bunch of health problems from going on
the diet and then getting off of
antidepressants almost like literally
almost killed him and then he was put on
a number of medications and it was just
like diet's not working what's going on
like he has symptoms diet's not working
and it took us quite a long time I think
because
he took ssris for a long time and I was
on them it took both of us a really long
time to be like oh these this is the
medication that's causing these problems
that's crazy and then a lot of doctors
too they're like oh you can experience
some side effects but it's not like this
side effect could ruin your life
because it's just this tiny little pill
right yeah like especially in young
girls I think it's the worst because
they're typically the first ones to get
on essentially life long HRT through a
birth control pill or something similar
to that and they end up at like 15 16
years old prescribed what is literally
going to be their Androgen and estrogen
they rely on for libido this and that
which is going to be sub-optimal but in
addition to that like that becomes such
a consistent part of your life you even
forget it's an like a part of the
equation a massively impactful one too
like the impact on testosterone free
testosterone levels and suppression of
it from birth control is
like astounding when you actually look
at how much you are [ __ ] up your
hormones as a girl who's on birth
control it's like your free testosterone
levels could drop by like 80 90 while
you're using it
wow yeah so like a lot of nuts a lot of
girls like I'm I'm sure you've seen the
literature on like impact on sexual uh
like preference for like type of you
know masculine versus less masculine men
or whatever that kind of thing yeah yeah
so that is definitely impacted heavily I
think from how like a lot of girls think
they're just asexual and have no sex
drive but in reality they're like
manually shutting down their system
levels didn't even consider that link to
okay I thought about the link to even
politically the link to that in birth
control like and the insanity that's
kind of going on right now like you
wouldn't want do you know what
percentage of the population is on birth
control I looked this up the other day I
think it was 60 of women who can get
pregnant are actively taking birth
control and 80 have taken it that could
be wrong but I'm pretty sure that's what
it is
um it's high whatever it is yeah which
would impact mate selection like
everybody's mate selection is impacted
in a more feminine man right yeah that's
the choice that's crazy there's some
data that suggests and may not be as
significant as you think in terms of
made selection but I definitely think I
mean it doesn't look that way it
definitely there's something to be said
though like regardless if your hormones
are plummeted it has an effect
physiologically like at best case
scenario you're just like not impacted
but worst case scenario and often times
like I'm pretty sure everyone knows a
girl who either had a side effect of
some sort from the birth control or
they're just operating with a state of
lowered sexual desire or lack thereof
entirely and they don't attribute it to
the birth control they just think that's
their Baseline State because since
they've been sexually active they've
been on the drug so they just assume
their entirety of their lives
essentially you know I just don't want
sex that much or I just am not that
interested in you know I could go
you know it they just Overlook it
entirely and it's a very very uh
problematic thing how again like
how hap as really men are put on
testosterone tails in comparison to how
haphazardly women are put on a synthetic
drug that's not even bioidentical it's a
synthetic progestin your body doesn't
produce this progestin like this is
technically actually an anabolic or it's
not an anabolic but it's a steroid it's
derived from there's an anabolic story
called nandralone that men in
bodybuilding use they chemically tweak
that drug because it's so suppressive
and cast like castrating at low dosages
and created orderly bioavailable analogs
of it that are used in women for
castration birth control like levo nor
gestural
um and a bunch of other synthetic 19 or
derivatives and then they use a
synthetic estrogen on top of that too
ethanol estradiol and you're just
operating off of like this you're just
like a pseudo-castrated human
essentially for years oh my gosh yeah
wow I haven't heard it that put put that
way that's horrible it was that's
horrible
um I was put on birth control because I
had like bad skin as a teenager and it
was like this will fix your skin and
then you're also on birth control yay
and that was like 14 and my mom told me
I remember she goes she didn't like
hammer it in like she should have she
she goes oh yeah when I was on birth
control it made me depressed and I was
just like well I was on ssris already I
was like I'm already depressed who cares
um which is a teenage response uh and I
think what it did though it's hard to
say because I was on so many like
mind-altering drugs Adderall ssris birth
control like so many things that it's
hard to say what that did specifically
but I I know one thing it did is it
blocked me out from any emotional
difference during my cycle right so when
I stopped taking it I was like oh I can
actually really tell when I'm ovulating
like I can actually feel that I feel
different I act in a slightly different
way and I can feel it and I was like
that's actually very cool
like that's a very cool thing to
experience after it just being like okay
you get your period once a month and
that's kind of it or you don't get your
period right because there's birth
control for that too every three months
um but that was really interesting and
no one had ever I hadn't had a
conversation anyway with anyone that was
like you know you should be able to
experience these like waves and hormones
and yeah it's messed up yeah medical
systems similar to the discussion of if
you're a guy who takes trt and you don't
need it how problematic is the recovery
process going to be to get back to like
a natural function on the flip side no
one talks about women who are on because
a lot of women skip the placebo pills
too or they're not Placebo the sugar
pills in their packs and they just stay
on like the straight hormones the entire
time to skip you know bleeding because
they don't want to deal with it yeah so
so that if you're on it for years on end
shutting yourself down trying to get
back to Natural function is not totally
different than a guy who's been on
steroids for years and then it's trying
to recover function too because you're
both in a state of like pseudo
castration and then you're trying to get
back to Baseline after years of exposure
you know you're you know kind of
reproductive system has not been
functional for a decade Plus in some
cases expecting you to recover in short
order and that it's going to be a smooth
transition is often not going to be the
case
yeah yeah that's pretty crazy yeah
that's that's crazy yeah well
okay I may be hitting you up for blood
tests okay for my five years on
Carnivore we'll see sure we'll see
um if people want to find you online and
they don't follow you already where
should they go
uh I think the best place is probably
YouTube uh more place more dates or
Instagram any kind of any main social
platforms I'm on and then if they want
to check out miracle for some of the
hormone stuff we discussed m-a-r-e-k
health.com and you can just go to the
just to get started if you want a blood
test you don't have to have a doctor to
look at it too you can just look at it
yourself and make your own informed
decision if you want to move forward
with medical oversight or not you can
just go to the lab test section there's
pre-designed panels for men as well as
for women and they've been audited by me
as well as numerous other medical
providers on our team and it's kind of
just like TurnKey done for you and
um hopefully it's going to be impactful
on people's quality of life is what I'm
hopeful for
so yeah that's good people can just like
purchase the test and then bring it to
LabCorp or wherever they want to go
yeah yeah so you would purchase it
online then you would get a requisition
form you could walk into a Lab Corp
wherever you live in the states and then
get it done and then from there you
could either have a provider or patient
care coordinator go over the test
results with you and then if warranted
you know proceed with some sort of
targeted recommendations thereafter but
there's no
um stipulation where you have to do all
of it you could just get a blood test
and see where you're at and kind of just
have that Baseline panel for reference
in the future if something goes awry
definitely something I would recommend
for majority of people
cool okay thank you very much for coming
on yeah no worries thanks for having me
[Music]